hi there today we're looking at
reconciling modern machine learning and
the bias-variance tradeoff by Mikhail
Belkin at all so this paper struck me as
interesting at ICML when I heard a talk
by Mike McKay Belkin and the the kind of
that the paper is very interesting in
terms of what it proposes about modern
machine learning so what's the problem
the problem is they can Trask what they
call classical machine learning and how
to understand machine learning namely in
terms of bias-variance tradeoff s-- and
modern machine learning where it's for
example deep neural networks which have
very different properties so basically
the best way to describe it is probably
with an example so let's say we have
four data points right here is a
coordinate system in two dimensions so
one two three four four data points
right yeah why not all right so these
four data points we want to fit a
function from X to Y Y is our target so
it's kind of a regression problem then
let's say we have just one parameter
which which we can use to describe our
function probably the best thing we
could do is to do something like this
right which is a line and the only
parameter here is the slope of that line
all right so the the kind of our model
would be this one line and it would pass
basically through the data and we'll
describe the data fairly well as you can
see if we have two parameters now we can
introduce for example a bias term and
not have the line at the origin so this
line here now we have the bias we
is the distance to this point to
describe it as well as the slope of this
line as parameters so two parameters and
if you look at this line here it
distracts it describes the data a bit
better than before right it passes kind
of through the center of the data now if
we go to three or four parameters let's
go to four parameters it's well known
that if I have the same number of
parameters as I have the as I have data
points actually actually fit the data
perfectly and how to do this it will be
like an order for polynomial which um
let's let's see if I can draw an order
for polynomial it needs to go okay well
no that's okay that's more than order
for in any case I can fit actually the
data perfectly now if you think about
all of these functions let's contrast
these alright let's contrast them and
let's look at what is the what is that
the data distribution probably right the
distribution is probably if I fill in
the rest of the data that is not in our
training set may be something like this
right so which of these functions
generalizes well to this general data
the unseen data probably the first
function not doing very poorly the first
function actually doing okay
the second function doing even better as
we saw right and then if we so if we add
a parameter to the first function it
gets better but if we then add more
parameters it gets worse
so this is kind of taught in current
machine learning classes as the
phenomenon of overfitting
whereas here here the function that has
the most parameters actually doesn't fit
well what is troubling now
is that if you think of things like
neural networks modern architectures
they actually have even more different
oftentimes more parameters then there
are data points in the data set so they
can fit the training data perfectly and
still have kind of spare room spare
capacity and these models actually
generalize fairly well so this paper
asks what's going on here and what they
propose is the following picture so here
we have a classical view of machine
learning on the x-axis is the the
complexity of age and you can think of
the complexity of the this is H is the
model class H is the class of all the
models you could fit so if if for
example it would be every linear model
with one parameter this was our first
model right there first model would be
somewhere here
one the complexity is one and then here
we'd have the complexity of two where we
added a parameter three parameters and
four parameters and this is what we saw
right at the beginning one parameter we
had some some pet training risk risk
here simply another term for a loss but
some training loss right fit and then as
we added a parameter the training loss
decreased right it got better and also
the test the test loss on the unseen
data decreased so it got better on the
test that as well as we added parameter
but then as we added more parameters it
was able to fit the training data better
and better going to almost zero risk
here but on unseen data the performance
actually got worse again and that's the
again this is the what we teach as
overfitting these authors proposes is
incomplete namely the picture actually
looks like this
and all we've done so far is look at
this left hand side here namely that
there is a peak here
this is called the interpolation
threshold and the interpolation
threshold is roughly at the point where
you have as many parameters as you have
data points and after the interpolation
threshold if you get give even more
parameters the training risk of course
stays low because you can fit the
training data perfectly from the
interpolation threshold forward but the
test risk actually decreases again and
this is really this is really
interesting and let me just preamp this
and say this is not due to
regularization so it's not because
people regularize their models or
anything like this in any case
regularization would actually move you
to less of a complexity of your model
class because now if you regularize
you're no longer able to fit certain
models as easily or converge to them so
the they proposed that this is happening
and they give some reason why this might
happening and they give some evidence
that this is happening so here is the
evidence that this is happening and they
do this here for example this is a
random Fourier features classifier so
what are random Fourier features they
describe them here so if you have a data
point X what you do is you push this
through a function which or you push
this through many of them you sample
capital n of these vectors V and of each
of the vectors V you take the inner
product and raise it raise it take the
exponential function of it and then
aggregate them and these these are these
random Fourier features these are the
random Fourier features and these then
are the weights that you learn so this
is basically a linear classifier but not
of the original features but of
intermediary
teachers which are fixed for a given
random seed and the good thing is here
you can sample you can decide how many
intermediary features that you want the
other good thing is if you let n go to
infinity this actually becomes a
infinite dimensional kernel machine so
it becomes a kernel SVM with a Gaussian
kernel which is operating in an infinite
dimensional space but if you don't go as
far then it's just an approximation to
that so this it's a cool it's a cool
model where you can choose how many
parameters you want so it's a perfect
model to explore this this phenomenon so
what are they doing they are doing the
following they take em nest and they
just apply this model and on the x-axis
here are the number of parameters that
they and the number of random Fourier
features that they construct and here
you can see the mean squared error on
the test set so as you can see at the
beginning the error goes down as
proposed right but then here is probably
this sweet spot of classical machine
learning after that you start to overfit
it goes up again
there's a giant peak and then it goes
down again
as you sow here 10,000 they I think they
do it with a subset of em nest if I
remember correctly and 10 around 10,000
is exactly the the number of data points
they use or multiplied by the classes I
don't remember correctly but in any case
at this number you have the same amount
of parameters as data points roughly or
and after that the the test error
decreases again so as you give more and
more and more features every every
single
a fire on this line is able to fit the
training data perfectly but they
successfully get less and less error on
the test set you can see it approaches
this this dotted line here which is if
you perfectly solve the infinite
dimensional problem so if you actually
use a kernel SVM to solve this problem
that that is kind of you can see this
gives you a lower bound so you can
really be can really shows nicely that
the around and for your features
classifier approximates this as you go
higher and higher with capital and it a
proxy actually approximates the kernel
SVM and this is really interesting that
this actually happens in practice and
what they also see here is when they
look at the norm of the solution so the
norm of the solution they calculate as
basically the the they want to use
ideally the norm in the Hilbert space
but they can't because it's hard to
compute so a proxy for this is simply
the norm of the weight vector that you
learn and the norm of the solution as
you add more parameters of course first
it goes up because you had more kind of
more parameters you fit each of them
they have some value and then it goes up
and it peaks at this interpolation
threshold there you have a really high
norm solution and after that the norm
goes down again of the solution and
again it approximates the norm of the of
the perfectly solved kernel machine so
that's extremely interesting and is a
part of an explanation
they give why this is happening namely
the following if if you have too many
parameters what you might do with the
correct inductive bias is
find a low norm solution and what does a
low norm solution mean a low norm
solution means a relatively simple
function so as you add parameters your
model is better and better able to find
a simple function that describes the
training data not in terms of um not in
terms of simple of less parameters but
simple in terms of how it moves between
the training data so if you imagine the
the training data again from before
actually and you imagine it a perfectly
fit this polynomial here right that we
drew before brothers if I have many many
many more parameters I can do something
like yeah I have many parameters but I
can be kind of looking but they have
late right so this something like this
here I grab this here I grab this
something like this and this moves
smoothly between the training data it
has many parameters because there's many
many squiggles here but it's a low norm
solution the low norm will cause the
solution to kind of be smooth whereas a
high norm solution that perfectly
interpolates the training data would
look something like this right
so the authors here say if you're
inductive bias is able to find a low
norm solution that perfectly fits the
training data then that will generalize
well and it turns out that modern
architectures tends to find low norm
solutions if you train them for example
with SGD and and that's a so-so
the combination of many parameters and
low known solutions will give you a
smooth function and the smoothness of
the function will be the thing that
generalizes to unseen data because the
smoothness kind of ensures that
everything in between the data will be
nicely kind of interpolated here here
all right
so that's the the perspective they go on
from these random Fourier features to
neural networks and what they do here is
they train a neural network on em nest
with a one hidden layer so there's two
weight layers now and again you can see
as the as the number of parameters so
this means basically the number of the
hidden no they increase the number of
hidden nodes in the hidden layer and as
they increase this that training and
test error go down training error
continues to go down test error goes up
until the interpolation threshold again
and then the test error drops again
while there the training error continues
to be almost zero and they do the same
thing with decision trees and random
forests and show the exact same thing
that there is this interpolation
threshold after which the test error
drops even though the training error is
almost zero so to me this is really
remarkable and they show this in the
appendix have many many more experiments
where they they show this phenomenon
happening on different data sets and on
different architectures here random relu
features and so on and it kind of gives
a new perspective on generalization and
why our models generalized so well they
finally conclude with why has it has not
been seen yet
and they give some nice reasons
basically that for example models where
you can choose the models where you can
choose the
the complexity for example random phoria
features are originally proposed as an
approximation to kernel machines if you
have too many data points and don't want
to compute as many features so they
they're basically only ever used in this
regime where the classical paradigm
holds and then neural networks on the
other hand often are simply made super
large and they say this peak here that
they show is very localized and you
might if you increase your neural
network maybe you try one at this size
this size this size and this size and
all you then see is kind of a downward
trajectory you kind of missed this peak
so it leads to the impression that
simply Oh bigger neural networks perform
better yeah so I found this interesting
I hope you did as well and definitely
check out more of this group's work that
was it for now
have a nice day